okay
the next topic
we're going to talk about is
convolutional neural networks or cnns
and
this is
what's used commonly used these days for
classifying natural images or images of
any kind but in particular natural
images
and here's a palette of of natural
images
you've seen a hundred different images
here this is a data set
that it's it's known as the c400 and the
hundreds stands for
100 different
image classes right so you can see
there's fish animals butterflies
cars
so they're natural images and they fall
into 100 classes so that's that's a lot
of classes
and each image is a 32 by 32 color image
okay so that's a little different to
what we worked with before
and
neural networks when they re-emerged in
in 2010 their big success story was
classifying images they got spectacular
results
and as a result of having these much
larger training sets and much stronger
much better compute in power
for c4 100 there's 50 000 training
images and test 10 000 test images
now each image here is a
three-dimensional array or feature map
so that means that it's got
a red green and blue channel so that's
the third dimension
and the the other two channels the red
green and blue channels are images that
are going to look like these but they
represent the three different colors and
each of those is going to be 32 by 32.
this is just a little schematic that
sort of gives intuition of our cnn's
work
so what it does here we've got a little
cartoon image of a tiger and the cnn
builds up an image in a kind of
hierarchical fashion
first it tries to identify little shapes
or or little color splotches or edges or
so on in in the image but small
typically small
so you can see in this cartoon it's
picked up an ear
it's picked up part of the mouth maybe
there's a little bit of red that's the
tongue so these are really small little
localized parts of the image
and then
if you go up the layers these here are
used as building blocks to build up more
composite aspects of the images they
piece together to form more com complex
shapes eventually assembling the target
image
and this hierarchical construction is
achieved using what's known as
convolution and pull-in layers
and that's where the name
convolution is where the cnn comes from
convolutional neural networks
okay so we're going to tell you about
both of these
layers the convolutional filter and the
pulling
layer
so here we showing you
using little matrices how convolution
filter works
so let's suppose your input image was
this one and we've just represented the
pixels as letters
and the convolution photo is itself a
little image and it's small
here we've shown a convolution folder
which is just two by two so it's just
four numbers arranged in a two by two
array
okay
now what we do is we take this two by
two array
and we move it on top
of
the left-hand part of the image so it
sits
on top of these four numbers
and then we multiply the elements
together and sum them up
so you can see that's what's happened
over here
we multiplied them together and sum them
up
right
so the a times the alpha the b times the
beta and so on
then we slide this filter along to the
right
just one column right so they're
overlapping
and we do it again and so there you can
see
the the the what's known as a dot
product between this little four by a
two by two block and this filter
and then we do it then we move down a
row and we do it again so now we use
these four guys here that's what's going
on over here and so on
so that operation is known as a
convolution
you've got a filter you've got the big
image and you do this convolution where
you slide this this little filter around
the image and do these dot products
so the way it works is if the little sub
image over which we hover in the filter
is similar to the filter
then that dot product computes a large
number
in other words it's detected something
that looks like itself in that place
otherwise it'll be a small number the
number will be low
okay so
if this fault is any good what it's
going to do is is it's going to make a
new image and that image is going to
highlight
parts of the image
where this little
image was seen basically or close to
being seen
and the other nice thing is that we
don't supply these little filters
they learned when you learn the network
and we're going to have many of them
so here's an illustration
target image is a tiger
and we've got two filters
right let's pretend these filters were
learned and so these are two small
little filters and so you can see this
one's got a vertical stripe with two
black stripes and a vertical white
stripe this one's got a horizontal
stripe
and we do the convolution
over the image they're gonna look for
vertical and horizontal stripes in the
image
and it's not 100 clear but you can see
when we do the vertical stripe one this
image of the tiger
tends to accentuate vertical stripes
and when we do the horizontal stripe one
it tends to accentuate the horizontal
stripes
again not perfect but it's it's kind of
doing the job
so the result of the convolution is is a
new feature map so this image here
consists of red green and blue channels
we've just shown one fault here but it's
got red green and blue channels but when
you do the convolution it produces a new
image right
also what we call a feature map
so since images have three colors
it turns out these filters do have have
as well
so you'll have a
filter for the red the filter for the
green and the filter for the blue
and then you do the dot product
separately on the red green and blue and
then you add up the results
and so from one color image you get one
new feature map
okay so that's the convolution
and again the weights in the filters are
learned in the network
we'll tell you a bit more about that in
a moment but let me tell you
also about pooling
so
yes yes let's say the feature map that
we obtained from doing a convolution
what pooling does
is and this is called max pooling
it takes non-overlapping blocks in this
case two by two blocks which is what we
actually use
and we replace each block by its maximum
right so here's the first two by two
block it's got one two three and zero
the maximum value in there is three so
we put in a three
the next block is five three one two the
maximum there is five we put a five
and so on and so you get a reduced image
which has got three five two and four
so this sharpens the feature
identification
if we thought of the convolution as
highlighting areas where we saw a
feature
by doing this pooling we sharpen things
and and we allow a little bit of
location in variance to where that
feature is by picking the place where
it's maximum it also reduces the
dimension by a factor of four
so in this case a factor of two in each
dimension
okay so here's the architecture of a
cnn
you'll see there's many convolve and
pool layers
here's the first convolved layer
and you can see we've got a number of
feature maps here
the input image was 32 we come out with
these feature maps are 32 by 32
well how come there's so many
well for each filter that we have we get
a new feature map
and so
in this case we've got one two three
four five six
okay well now we think of these new
feature maps
as new channels
along this hierarchy we had three color
channels for the input
we've now create created eight channels
okay
we then do a pool a max pool layer
and
we
and
say that filters are typically small
example three by three
right
each each filter creates a new channel
in the convolution load then in this
case we see eight
as the pooling reduces the size the
number of full systems is typically
increased
okay so we had eight here we we still
have eight here but they've dropped in
size to
half the the dimensions in each
direction
and now
we have filters that get applied to
these guys
but now the remember this we see in
eight channels here so the filter has
have has to have eight channels as well
remember we had three channels in the
filter for the input
we've got eight channels here each
filter has has eight channels
one
one for each of these
feature maps here
and because things are getting smaller
in size we have more filters and so then
the output becomes
we increase the number of feature maps
that we produce
is what's happening here we're going we
start on the left with the features are
very local very fine and then as you
pull and convolve point evolve the
features are more and more coarse is
that right yes they're not as local as
you move up
yeah that's right because that max
pooling is allowing the feature to sort
of move around and and get localized
and and sort of zone in where it is
because you could have two images of a
tiger and the even though they've been
standardized in some way yeah it could
be in different places for sure
and so this allows that kind of uh
location in variance it's almost like
looking through the camera and a lens
you start very close and then you sort
of pan back right yes
so this carries on right we keep on
going and
we have a max pool layer then we have
another convolved layer
each time the max pool drops dimensions
and the images get smaller and smaller
and we actually go all the way until
we're down to some really small images
like two by two
and then we just collapse with what's
known as flattening
into the individual pixels in all those
images and we have a fully connected
layer to the output layer where there's
a hundred classes so
that that's how it works
and like we say the number of layers can
be very large
so there's a one network that was
trained
on on a thousand
class image database known as imagenet
and it's got 50 layers
right so here you've seen about eight
layers this one's got 50 layers and
we're going to demonstrate it in in a
little while
in fact we demonstrated it right now
so
just to remind you
the parameters or the the weights in in
these networks
are the filters
and if we go back to our little um
filters here you can see
these four numbers here are weights that
need to be learned
for a color image we're going to have
three channels so there's going to be
four times three is 12 weights for one
filter if you have many filters the
weights add up
then when you go to these ones here
we've got eight channels and now each
filter has eight channels so the number
of weights in each filter is eight times
say we said three by three
for the cnn so they add up right so
those that's where the that's where the
parameters come in and they get learned
during training
so
there's imagenet's one big image
training database there's even bigger
ones today and massive neural networks
are trained on these on these image
databases
and trains used using distributed
software
by companies like google and facebook
and the nice thing is they make these
pre-trained networks available
so
here's a collection of photographs
taken from
a photograph album
of natural images
and we're going to use the pre-trained
resnet
network to try and classify these images
and in the lab we go through how we we
show you how to do that but here we're
just going to show the result and
this procedure will is going to produce
probabilities
for each of the 100 in this case a
thousand classes but we're going to show
the top three
and for the first one it says gives 0.83
probability to a flamingo and indeed it
was a flamingo
this guy is a is known as a cooper's
hawk
they're abundant in northern california
it calls it a kite which is a kind of
raptor gives sixty percent uh
probability to that second guess is a is
a great grey l
third guess with very small probability
is is a robin that's way off
here we zoom out of of um the cooper's
hawk picture and you can see it's
sitting on a water fountain
and the network gets confused so now it
classifies this picture as a fountain
and ignores the hawk
and then
it seems to go off the of the rails
because the next guess is a hook a nail
and then the next one's a hook
here's a picture of a cute little dog
he's actually a lasso apso which is a
kind of
tibetan um guard dog
it gets classified as a tibetan terrier
and they look somewhat similar and with
56 probability
and then the second guess is alassa
which is correct and the third is the
cocker spaniel
here's a cat
line in a curled up position
and this completely
fooled the network i thought it was a
old english sheepdog
way down in the list is a persian cat
and
slightly higher as a sheetsu dog
and the last one this is a cape weaver
bird in its nest
and it gets classified as a jacoma which
is a is a kind of bird that hangs out in
trees and builds nests and trees the
second and third guests are also birds
you can go back to the picture of the
cnn i just was unclear about something
you say pre-trained
so when you apply this now to the the
photographs which part is
ke is obtained from the database and and
which weights are trained for this data
oh i see in this in this case rob we we
took the network as is and just
classified the images
also there's no training at all there's
no training in this case there's no
training but i think you're getting onto
another point which is interesting as
well rob
about using pre-trained networks for
other tasks right
so
when you train a neural network on
natural images either
the you know
let's say the resnet one that we have
here
a lot of the early layers of the network
are just picking up
features in in natural images
and a lot of the training goes to
learning those
um you may have a problem where you've
got say medical images you know of of
lungs or or
mammograms or something like that and
those pre-trained features can be
helpful in in
you know in classifying or diagnosing
medical images so what you can do is you
can you can pick out those pre-trained
layers from an image network
and then you can use some training data
for the problem at hand to learn the
remaining layers and i guess the one is
for mammograms in my tip we only have a
few hundred training observations but
their pre-training might come from 100
000 images right so there's a lot more
data for the pre-training yeah